NARRATOR:
This is the Shark Tank,
where hopeful entrepreneurs
get a once-in-a-lifetime chance
to pitch the sharks...
My name
is moziah Bridges,
and I am the C.E.O.
of Mo's Bows.
...In hopes
of getting an investment
to start, grow,
or save their businesses.
Who would like to experience
the drink of the gods?
Oh!
Ugh!
People paid for this?
NARRATOR: The entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
We're on track to do
$1.5 million in sales.
I believe I am an n.B.T. --
The next big thing -- and --
oh, my goodness. did you just
say "n.b.t. -- next big thing"?
Yeah.
NARRATOR: If the sharks
hear a great idea...
I smell a royalty deal.
NARRATOR: ...They're ready to
invest using their own money.
And they're willing
to fight each other
for a piece of the action.
What are sales gonna be
this year?
$4.2 million.
I'll give you $1.5 million.
I'd like to split it in the
middle and go $1.75 million.
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
HERJAVEC: Wow.
CORCORAN: Wow.
Under what planet would that
make sense to an investor?
I promise you, we will do a
minimum of $10 million in sales.
What?
Oh!
This is the shortest pitch
in "Shark Tank" history.
NARRATOR:
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Barbara Corcoran went
from waiting tables in Manhattan
to building the city's
preeminent real-estate empire.
Daymond John is
a fashion and branding expert
who grew
his homemade clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand fubu,
with over $6 billion
in retail sales to date.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold his first internet
companies for over $350 million.
And Mark Cuban,
notorious billionaire
entrepreneur, tech guru,
and the outspoken owner
of the NBA's Dallas Mavericks.
First into the tank
is a reinvention
of an ancient beverage.
Hello, sharks.
I'm Jon fotheringham.
And I'm
Dr. Eric durtschi.
We're the creators
of crio,
and we're seeking
$1 million
in exchange for a 10%
equity stake in our business.
Imagine
if you could combine
two of America's
biggest passions --
coffee and chocolate --
into one amazing new drink
and tap into the $75 billion
coffee, tea,
and chocolate markets.
For thousands of years,
the Maya of central America
prepared a chocolaty drink
called xocoatl --
the drink of the gods.
After years
of experimenting,
I reinvented
this delicious drink
made with
100% cocoa beans.
And it's
incredibly healthy.
Crio has zero fat, zero sugar,
zero cholesterol,
only 10 calories per cup,
and more antioxidants
than pomegranate juice
or blueberries.
It also contains a natural
stimulant called theobromine
that gives you long-lasting,
gentle energy.
So you can say goodbye
to the spike and crash
of jittery energy
you get from coffee.
In short, crio is cocoa
the way it was meant to be.
Now, who would like
to experience the
drink of the gods?
All right, sharks,
you're really in for a treat.
For $1 million,
it better be a hell of a treat.
DURTSCHI: We've got
a couple of things there.
Crio can be brewed at home
or in coffee shops.
Now, you can
have it plain.
The one that you're
going to have that's iced
is called iced coconut crio.
This has a little bit of cream
added to it.
Oh!
Ugh!
Ugh.
Ugh, I don't like taste
of that.
Not a fan, guys. I'm out.
Not for me. I'm out.
JOHN:
Yeah, it really is horrible.
I'm out.
Okay, so this is the shortest
pitch in "Shark Tank" history.
I'm gonna let you
have a chance to explain
why you're worth
$10 million.
Well, this year, we're on track
to do $1.5 million in sales.
We've sold over 276,000 units
over the past two years.
We should be in 1,000 new stores
in the coming six months.
We've done
hundreds of demos.
I would say
that 9 out of the 10 people
that try it in the store
like it.
What do you think
about that?
Hey, look,
just 'cause I don't like it
doesn't mean there
aren't people who do like it.
O'LEARY: Which one
of my assumptions is wrong?
This is a commodity.
Anybody can package this
and sell it.
No one's ever heard of it,
so you've got a marketing job
from hell.
Why are you asking
for $1 million for 10%?
How -- how -- under what
scenario on what planet
would that make sense
to an investor?
This is actually a
product that we've had
a lot of interest from
from some
very large companies.
I've actually found references
over 150 years old
from people
who have tried to do this.
And they've not been able
to do that for a few reasons.
The roasting is something
that's completely different
from what's done
with normal chocolate products
as well
as coffee products.
Oh, so you're telling me
the process
by which you make your crio bean
is proprietary and unique?
Absolutely.
And that is something
we have patent pending.
Who are you selling it to?
Through what medium?
FOTHERINGHAM: 60% of our sales
are in grocery stores.
We're in 500 stores
currently --
on slate to be in 1,500 stores
by the end of the year.
Do you have reorders
in this short period of time?
Absolutely.
And I know your experience
is different,
but to be honest
with you,
a lot of times,
people try it their first try,
and you don't know
what to expect.
You're either thinking
hot chocolate
or you're thinking
coffee.
This is neither one
of those.
O'LEARY:
Why is that a good thing?
You have to educate
an entire generation
that they should be
drinking this,
supposedly, because it's better
for them than coffee
and that the taste is,
at least, equivalent.
I mean, I can see people --
I think we have
five opinions here,
and everybody thought
the taste --
no, not me. I thought
the taste was fine.
What you were expecting
was something that tasted
like coffee.
No, that's not what
I was expecting at all.
I was looking for
a coffee replacement,
not knowing
what to expect.
It just tastes like cocoa beans
mashed up, ripe,
and hot water put
in, and there wasn't
enough cocoa put in.
Well, Mark, they're --
they're selling $1.5 million.
Some people like it.
So, here's the thing --
how much you making
on the $1.5 million?
This year,
we should do $150,000.
So let's just
think about this.
That's awesome.
That's all that matters, right?
You're asking me to pay
100 times your profit.
Well, and so,
part of that is --
I mean,
I have to punish you now.
Why in the world
would you value yourself
at such a number
that it is impossible --
that's what they've been trying
to figure out for 150 years.
[ laughter ]
Nobody would ever pay you
that valuation.
You're not worth
100 times your profit.
I think you're screwed.
I'm out.
And then there
was Barbara.
Barbara,
what are you gonna do?
I think you're screwed.
I'm out.
[ laughter ]
Oh, Barbara!
I'm sorry.
That was so --
guys, we didn't mean
to be that mean. I mean --
no, because the wrong
evaluation -- it's too
bad you did that.
yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, I apologize for us --
the initial response.
I didn't expect it.
All of us here tried
it, except for Kevin.
What are you
apologizing for?
Because we try to be very
supportive entrepreneurs.
You guys --
how can you be
supportive of this? My God.
No, somebody asks you for
a crazy number, and you
want to be supportive?
You're en-- you're --
you're encouraging America
to come here and ask
for stupid valuations?
All I can tell you is the first
615 times I drank beer,
I thought
it tasted horrible, right?
Nothing to do with the taste.
The valuation was insane.
Yeah, but, Kevin, you're basing
on the value today. They're --
oh, really?
I want to pay --
and I -- and I promise you,
we really wanted a deal
because you guys have so much
to bring to the table.
But why do you -- why did you
price it that way?
But I promise you
that next year,
we will do a minimum
of $10 million in sales.
I hope you do, guys.
I really, really hope you do.
We hope you prove us wrong.
O'LEARY: But you guys
didn't finish the story.
It's 150 years old.
Mayans were drinking it.
They no longer exist.
[ laughter ]
Thank you.
Good luck, you two.
Well, they obviously
didn't get it.
Kevin, with all due respect,
you're like a broken record.
I'm right every time.
It's always -- it's --
you don't look at the
future. look where they
were going with it.
The future is the Mayans.
They're history.
[ laughter ]
NARRATOR: Next into the tank
are entrepreneurs
with a business profiting
from competitive thrill-seekers.
Greetings, sharks.
My name is Brad scudder.
And I'm Rob Dickens.
We're from Boston,
Massachusetts,
our company
is Rugged Races,
and we're seeking $1 million
for 10% of our company.
So, what is
Rugged Races?
We operate a popular
5k obstacle-course race series
in 20 cities across the country
called rugged maniac.
At our events,
participants of all ages,
all genders,
all shapes and sizes,
will complete
a challenging running course
featuring
25 epic obstacles.
But these aren't
the pop-up kiddie obstacles
you'll see
at our competitors' events.
At rugged maniac,
participants will climb over
towers of shipping containers,
rocket down
100-foot water slides,
crawl through tunnels of mud,
and even jump over fire,
all while running
through a combination
of forest, fields, ski slopes,
and even motocross tracks.
In short, rugged maniac
strikes the perfect balance
between fun
and physicality
with our award-winning courses
and our day-long festival.
So which one of you sharks
is ready to get rugged with us?
And just to show you
what we're all about,
we've got this video clip
right here.
[ rock music plays ]
Wow.
I didn't even know
you existed,
but I know about
your competitor.
You mean like
tough mudder?
How are you different
than that?
We're -- we're different
in this sense.
Basically, tough mudder
is a 12-mile course, right,
with about 20 obstacles.
We have 25 obstacles
over three miles.
So it's more about the obstacles
and less about the running.
And being
a three-mile course,
it's much more accessible
to the general public
than something like
a 12-mile course would be.
Are you saying this
is a tamer version of that --
something that Barbara
would do?
Oh, I could handle
the 12 miles.
It's this little short guy
over here
that wouldn't have a shot
at it.
Uh, but we get people
of all shapes and sizes
at our events, truly,
from 77-year-old guys to,
you know,
mother/daughter teams,
14-year-old and up.
Is it more workout
or more party?
We think we strike
an excellent balance
between the workout
and the party.
Because it's a shorter race,
it takes, you know,
an average of an hour
or a little bit more to finish.
People are -- are exhausted,
but they're still exhilarated.
Do people bring alcohol?
No.
No. No.
Or do you sell it?
Yes, we sell alcohol.
HERJAVEC:
You sell alcohol?
It's a big outdoor fest--
it's a big outdoor festival.
Oh, hell yeah!
Pump, pounds, puke, right?
Exactly. Exactly.
I mean, it's fun.
It's -- it's a fun event.
So, what are sales gonna be
this year?
This year --
$4.2 million.
Wow.
Wow. Good for you.
Ooh.
And how many courses?
20 cities nationwide.
How much out of the $4.2 million
did you profit?
$1 million.
But next year,
without investment,
we're projecting
$6.5 million in revenue,
$2.2 million
in profits.
Talk about the industry.
There's some monsters
out there.
Sure, sure.
You know,
what's the difference?
So, basically,
you've got -- you've got
two kind of at the top --
the warrior dash 5k,
tough mudder 12 mile.
And why have they gotten
so much bigger than you guys?
First movers
in the market.
And how big are they, rob?
How big are they?
They have, like,
40 events.
45 events
across the country.
HERJAVEC: But -- but in terms
of revenue, take a guess. How
big would they be?
I think they're
about $30 million.
So would you guys say
this industry's
about $100 million a year?
Much larger.
Oh, more than that.
Rob, what are -- what are you
gonna do with the $1 million?
We've, uh --
we've taken that money
and invested it in other brands
that we own. um...
What -- so, now, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
W-what do you mean,
other brands?
DICKENS:
Wait, wait. No, no.
What are we gonna do
with the $1 million
that we would get from you?
JOHN: Yes.
Oh.
Sorry. What million
were you talking about, Brad?
I thought you wanted to know
what we did with our profits.
Yeah.
Well, we want
to know that, too.
Oh, well, all right, great.
What did you do
with the $1 million in profit?
DICKENS: Let me show you
exactly what we've done
with that other money.
Okay, let's see.
JOHN: Let's see it.
All right, here it is.
[ rock music plays ]
Oh, you guys are doing
these things?
It's so stupid.
CORCORAN: [ laughs ]
HERJAVEC:
That's a great idea.
Rob, explain to me
what I saw.
You saw running with the bulls
here in the U.S.
Okay.
Anybody get hurt?
We had some
minor injuries --
couple concussions,
a broken arm.
The injury rate --
[ laughter ]
People paid for this?
DICKENS: Oh, yeah.
About the same prices
as rugged maniac -- about $50.
But is that part
of this deal?
It can be.
That's a separate --
that's a separate company.
Separate LLC?
Lawyers, lawyers, lawyers.
Have you never
seen the show?!
Greedy, greedy pigs.
We have. We have.
I give you $1 million --
I don't -- I don't get to wet
my beak on the bull deal?
no.
Of course
we get the bulls!
Are you --
are you guys kidding?
No.
Come on.
You can't be serious.
Of course
that's not gonna work.
They're full of bull.
Now, I give you a chance
to change your mind.
DICKENS: Okay.
We would want more
money for you to get
involved with the bulls.
Why?!
So, the bull run is --
is a separate entity.
All right,
why don't we entertain it?
How much more would it be
to be pa--
$2 million
for 10% of the bull run.
$2 million for the bull
and $1 million for the rugged?
Yeah.
So 3 million bucks
gets 10% of both?
Yep.
Brad, what are the sales
in the second company?
$280,000
at the first event.
But d-do you realize
that your expertise
is not rugged maniac.
Your expertise is in putting on
adventure events.
The bull run is just another
variant of this same thing.
DICKENS:
That's exactly right.
And so, the growth potential
with this company
is not just
within rugged maniac.
Guys, what's the cash flow
gonna be next year in --
under your optimistic scenario
for both companies?
Whew! I mean, we
think they can be
a $20-million event this year.
Guys,
I like the business,
but if I come in
and give you money
and all of a sudden, it's like,
"where's Brad and rob?"
"oh, they're chasing
the bulls," right,
what am I gonna say to you
as an investor
when I'm not
getting your full attention?
"I want a piece
of the bulls."
O'LEARY: No kidding.
No, that's not
what I'm gonna say.
I'm gonna say,
"they can die," right?
I want a return
on my investments,
or I'm suing your ass because
you have a conflict of interest.
No investor says, "Oh, the
existing business is dying?
Sell me a piece
of the new one."
O'LEARY: No, you don't do that
to investors.
You align your interests
with them 100%.
When you start talking about
$1 million,
you don't screw around.
DICKENS: Right, right.
That's a real investment.
Sure.
HERJAVEC: Rob, the other --
the -- the element for me --
I love the idea.
I also really love the fact
that you're building a customer
base for the other events
that you can hold later on.
For me, they're together.
Here's an offer for you.
Sure.
Both businesses combined --
I'll give you $1.5 million
for 25% of the entire thing.
Okay.
Is that the only offer
that we have?
Mark, you said you were
interested. Would you --
CUBAN: No, I'm very --
I love the one business.
I-if I didn't know
about this other business,
I'd probably make an offer
right now, right?
Sure.
But I want to hear
what you say to rob.
I think I know, but --
I think I'm giving you
a fair offer.
I think the business is worth,
what, six times ebitda --
1.5 times revenue,
roughly.
Right.
And I'm pricing in.
I think that's generous.
I'm pricing it in
because I see the upside
in the other business.
Okay.
Asking for $1 million
for this business
was already challenging.
Having another agenda
and another business
on the other side,
my gut feeling is and my
instinct is that no matter what,
I would be screwed working
with you, I wouldn't trust you.
I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you for your
consideration.
You know, a funny thing happened
to me watching you here today.
You came out here, I thought,
"what good-looking guys.
Man, they look the part.
What a great video."
but then
somewhere along the way,
the surprise of the bulls
and, "Oh, yeah.
we'll wrap that into the deal."
And I don't think maybe
you intended it that way,
but for some reason,
you lost my trust.
But either way, I'm out.
Sorry to hear that, but we thank
you for your consideration.
Well, guys, you have --
you have, uh, one --
we have an offer...
You have an offer
on the table.
...From -- yes, we --
yes, we do.
What are you gonna do?
And that's an offer
that's...Lower than
what we had wanted, but --
no, let me make you an offer
higher than what you want.
Well, no, of course.
I get it.
[ laughs ]
Anyone else want to throw
an offer in the ring?
I'm still listening.
Well, Mark,
your concern is
that you -- you want us to focus
all our energies on one.
CUBAN: No, no, no.
it's not that.
You came in, and you tried
to sell us one business,
and you
separated the two.
You're overvaluing the other
business, in my opinion.
And if you have such a-a
high opinion of that business,
that's probably where a lot
of your attention's going to be.
And as an investor,
I don't think it's worth
the -- the value
that you're assigning to it,
because you've had one event
for $200,000.
Because the --
Mark, are you saying
my value's too high?
Yes.
Wow. Now Mark's
making me nervous about,
"am I overpaying?"
NARRATOR:
Two sharks are out.
Robert has made an offer,
but Mark's concerns may
have caused a change of heart.
Because the --
Mark, are you saying
my value's too high?
Yes.
Wow. Now Mark's
making me nervous about,
"am I overpaying?"
$1.5 million -- 25%.
That gives you about
a $6 million value
for the combined businesses.
The longer we wait,
the -- the less comfortable
I'm starting to feel.
Let me cloudy the waters
a little bit here
and maybe give you a --
well, let -- let --
tell me what --
hang on, Robert.
you may want to hear this.
I think your offer
should be for 33% -- 1/3.
You because a third partner
with these guys.
And then I'd go in
50/50 with you.
[ laughs ]
Hmm.
I'm good with that.
I like going up to 1/3.
$1.5 million for 1/3
of the combined businesses.
I'm with you, uncle Kevin.
Yeah, I thought
you might be,
because I think
you did overpay.
[ laughs ]
rob, isn't it interesting
what's happened?
You had an offer at here.
Now we're here.
Sure.
The longer we stay here...
So, what I would be
willing to do...
Is $1.5 million,
but it's for 25%
of the two companies combined.
Okay.
We're going to go discuss this,
consider both offers,
and come back.
I'm not sure what there is
to discuss, Mark.
You made a better offer
than we did.
Yeah, Mark made the same
as your initial.
The challenge is,
when they come back,
do you drop this dead weight
right here
and go back
to your initial offer?
Then you're overpaying.
I don't think they're
gonna take either offer.
Oh, I think they will.
O'LEARY: Okay, gentlemen, let's
summarize what's happened here.
You have two distinct offers.
The first, from Mr. Cuban,
is for $1.5 million
for 25% of your company.
Which, by the way,
was the exact same offer I made,
and he spent half an hour
telling you how bad
your business is.
I know, I know.
O'LEARY: The other offer
is for the same amount of money
for 33 1/3%
of your business.
DICKENS: Mm-hmm.
What are you going to do?
We went out there
and discussed it.
We'd -- we'd like to eventually
strike a deal with you.
We wanted to come back in
and say,
listen, we do $2 million
for -- for the 25%.
Instead of doing that,
we'd like to split it in the
middle and go $1.75 million.
Deal.
Deal? All right.
JOHN: I told you guys.
Go to work, baby.
Looking forward to it.
Absolutely.
We'll make some money.
Knew you'd lose out, but,
Robert, why did you do that?
And thank you
for your considerations.
Thanks, guys.
I'm fired up.
Thank you.
DICKENS:
We are very excited.
We took that offer
from Mark
because we realized that Mark
offers more than just money.
Mark offers his experience,
he offers his connections.
You know, only great things
can come from it.
Well done.
$1.75 million?
For 25%.
I'm actually surprised that
they came down in the valuation.
Hmm.
[ exhales sharply ]
NARRATOR: Last season,
father-and-son entrepreneurs
Keith and Brandon marz
pitched the sharks a new way
of getting your daily vitamins.
We came here wanting
to be partners with you.
Together, we can make
a lot of money.
You got a deal, Lori.
GREINER: Great.
Whoo!
This is gonna be great.
Very excited.
NARRATOR: Let's see how
marz sprays is doing now.
Business has been booming
since we did a deal with Lori.
All right, guys.
Unbelievable start to our
international success.
Before "Shark Tank,"
we had about $150,000 in sales.
Since "Shark Tank,"
in just over a year,
we have over $4 million
of sales.
KEITH: And we know
that $10 million
is just around
the corner.
BRANDON: Looks good.
Over the last year,
we've spent a lot of time
fine-tuning
our product.
We've changed
the packaging,
we've enhanced
the flavor profile.
These products are perfect
for consumers now.
That's really good.
There it is.
[ gasps ]
BRANDON:
Lori has helped us
get into two
of the largest retailers
in the world --
Walmart and Walgreens.
You guys repackaged
this beautifully.
We are now in thousands
of stores nationwide.
I knew it was a hero,
but to hit $4 million
that fast --
unbelievable.
This is just
the beginning, guys.
Yes!
Yay!
Coming to "Shark Tank" was truly
an incredible experience.
It allowed us to showcase
our products to the world,
and it opened doors that we
never would've thought
could've been opened.
NARRATOR: Next up is a product
created by a college student
to help him excel at school.
Welcome to class,
everyone.
My name is Mr. Hiltbrand,
and I'll be your teacher today.
Do you ever find yourself
struggling to focus
with all of today's
many distractions,
like McKay over here?
Yeah, well, welcome to the life
of a college student.
These distractions -- they've
got no effect on Jess and I.
And that's because
we've taken Cerebral Success.
Cerebral success
is an amazing brain supplement
that works to boost
the four areas of brain power.
It'll revitalize your focus,
memory, mental agility,
and overall brain health.
Trevor, you forgot
to take your pills.
You didn't even tell me
what you want.
So, today,
I'm looking for $75,000
in exchange for 20% equity
in my business.
Didn't forget my pills.
That was coming later.
CORCORAN: [ laughs ]
So, Cerebral Success contains
ginkgo biloba,
schizandrol-a, omega 3 dha,
huperzine, vinpocetine,
choline, and bacopa.
Yeah, Kevin. Bacopa.
But, sharks, pills?
They're old-school.
Introducing Cerebral Success
brain-boosting shots.
These little shots
will contain the same
tested and loved formula
as their older brother,
while being the perfect
point-of-purchase item
at every campus in every
bookstore nationwide.
Sharks, I need your help
to make Cerebral Success
a worldwide success.
Can you show us all
a bottle?
Sure.
So these are
just prototypes, so...
There's nothing
in here, right?
HERJAVEC: How did you
come up with it?
So, I came up with it
while I was a college student.
I, uh -- I always kind of fo--
struggled to focus, and, uh --
no kidding.
Really?
[ chuckles ] Yep.
And so, I-I was kind of mixing
my own different ingredients,
different supplements,
for my own purpose, and --
and so, is there any scientific
proof that this works?
All of my ingredients have had
clinical studies done on them.
No, I know, but the --
the combined product --
which means
absolutely nothing.
Have you done any studies
or any tests
that the combined product
works?
We've had
over 60,000, um...
Can't remember?
60-- 60,000 servings, sorry.
You're not doing yourself
any favors, Trevor.
What were your sales
in the pills?
So, we've sold 6--
we-we've sold almost 900 bottles
in the pill form.
Dollar-wise?
6-- about $60,000.
You're selling those
for 70 bucks a pop?
Yep.
Can I see that? That's --
check this out.
so --
what's your cost
on it?
63 cents.
Um, it's about --
it's about $10.
We have really expensive
and high-quality ingredients.
All the ingredients
listed there --
O'LEARY:
Trevor, if I go into gnc
and I go to the sector
that gives me supplements
to enhance focus,
mental abilities,
there's plenty
of offerings.
Why are you
different?
So, we're specifically designed
for college students.
most brain sup--
what?
How's that possible?
So, most brain supplements
are more geared
towards elderly people.
Like Barbara.
[ laughs ]
Let me explain.
Can I explain?
So, my product
has these four areas,
whereas most --
most brain supplements,
they only target
brain health.
Mine throws in
the mental agility.
Trevor, how do you
sell this today?
You're at $60,000 in sales,
which, by the way --
all online.
All online?
Yep.
So, how do you know
it works?
Reviews from our customers.
We've had --
that's it?
So, we're averaging about
three bottles per customer.
Customers keep buy--
coming back.
So, if I buy this, how many
pills do I have to take?
How long before
my memory improves or I get --
immediately you feel the effect
and you do better on your test?
So, it's -- it's designed
to feel in the short term
and for, like, effects
in the long term.
So if you take it once --
say you're cramming
for a test --
it'll help you recall more
information in the morning.
If you take it
consistently,
it'll have long-term benefits
for your memory,
for your focus,
for your mental health.
Look, you -- you can -- you can
convince anybody of anything
for a short period of time.
You don't --
you don't really believe
that this is gonna lead
to Cerebral Success, do you?
I-i really do believe it.
I picked a collection
of -- of --
of supplemental ingredients
that I wanted in my product,
and then I had
the professionals,
the manufacturers,
the gmp-certified facilities
help me put it together,
make sure it's all legit,
make sure they -- they don't
interact with each other.
But what about a kid
who's studying for an exam,
he's a nervous wreck,
he's been drinking all night,
and he takes 15, 20
of these pills?
He'll have the dance
of the flaming sphincter.
[ laughter ]
No, let me ask you,
though.
That's it.
Now, what is the downside
to a substantial overdose?
Just like
any other supplement,
if -- if you're super-sensitive
to caffeine --
JOHN: So, Trev, I don't want
to discredit you,
and I know, you know,
you're a young entrepreneur,
and you just want to get out
there and make some money
and -- and -- and work
on your company,
but you just don't have
any credibility in the market.
I'm out.
Okay.
Yeah, Trevor,
I, you know --
but they're all successful.
This is a massive,
massive market, with --
Trevor, just because
something's a-a massive market
doesn't mean
that your --
the demand's not there?
No, no, no.
H-h-hey, Trevor, what?
You're gonna stand there
and you're gonna start telling
me about the business
just because there's
a massive market?
I was gonna tell you
about the demand.
Focus used to be
a struggle for me.
Hey, Trevor, anyb--
anybody can sell anything.
I'm -- I'm not
a big believer in it.
Let me paint one -- let me paint
one quick -- quick picture.
Look, I -- before I forget,
I'm out.
CORCORAN:
[ chuckles ]
for those of you
who are still in,
let me paint a picture
real quick.
Imagine you're
a college student.
Imagine you're going
to wherever they sell
convenience items on campus,
and they see this product --
something that says,
"boosts memory, boosts focus,
boosts mental alertness,
and boosts brain health."
whether -- whether you think my
credentials are there are not,
do you think that they would buy
that product or not?
JOHN:
That's not what we're saying.
We're saying that
in our position,
we just don't
necessarily feel
that you have
the credibility to do that.
I don't even think it's
about his credibility.
This is about ethics
and integrity.
Yes.
Have you read
the warning on here?
Yes. I mean, I've writ--
I wr-- I wrote the warning.
"before taking, consult
a health-care professional
"prior to consumption.
"or if you have any pre-existing
medical conditions
or any prescription medications,
do not use this product."
I mean, you're not --
that's on --
but that's on everything.
but why am I saying that?
No, that's just
to protect myself.
That's just to protect
myself from --
JOHN: It's all about ethics.
We care about ethics here.
And if you really want to deal
with a shark without ethics,
then why don't you
just talk to Kevin?
[ laughter ]
look, I-I mean, I feel like
I'm a very ethical person.
I would never want to, you know,
mislead anybody.
Look, I --
Trevor, you know what I hated
most about your presentation?
What's that?
There's good money, and then
there's dirty money.
I hated your example
where you said
a college student
who didn't have enough sleep --
would they shell out money
for something like this?
And I'm amazed
that you're making
a conscious decision
to go after this kind of money.
There's a lot of ways
to be successful in life.
Why take this path?
Because I believe in it.
I mean, I've used it,
and it works.
And I've had customer
who have used it --
hallelujah. this is America.
do anything to make a buck.
I'm kind of confused
on why you guys
are painting this
as a -- as super-unethical --
O'LEARY: I am not --
I'm trying to figure out,
can I make a return in
the supplemental market
with your strategy?
But you haven't articulated one.
I'm out.
Thank you.
CUBAN: Look, if you had
come in here and said,
"I want to do
a controlled test.
"I so believe at this
that I want to be able
to demonstrate
that this works."
that's not what you
came in to do.
You -- you got a good marketing
pitch, you got big margins,
and so, you can --
you can just do it,
and that's what much of
the supplement business
is all about.
Not for me. I'm out.
Thank you.
Barbara?
What are your thoughts?
Um, I happen to have
a lot of close experience
with people
who can't hold attention.
One is my husband, bill,
who's a super-high-I.Q. Guy
and has been on Adderall
his entire life.
He orders anything
and everything
and tries everything out so
that he doesn't take Adderall.
And certain things work,
and then he's functional.
Another experience --
my kid went to a high-pressure
ivy league college,
and he tells me that kids
trade a-adderall
faster than beer.
It's the drug of choice,
so there is a real need
for kids to have something
to help them concentrate.
But here's the thing --
I'm concerned
about the liability.
If you would do
a contingent deal
where I have to get some kind
of liability coverage --
[ groaning ]
I don't need
your help here, Mark.
So if you'd be willing to
make a small contingency
on that deal --
so, Barbara, no matter
what chemical
or anything he puts in there
that may kill somebody...
no, I read the chemicals.
...As long as you're insured
if he kills somebody,
you're fine.
Let me tell you. Anything
wrongly taken can kill somebody.
Just insurance
if somebody dies.
You know what?
I'm gonna take a shot at it.
What is your offer?
My offer is $75,000
with that contingency for 40%.
Oh, Barbara. Barbara.
So, she has actually cut
your valuation in half --
offered you $75,000 --
no, he's not asking
for an interpreter,
thank you very much.
What do you think?
You're making me ill.
I'm very aware
of the valuation.
You're making me ill,
Barbara.
I can't believe you made
an offer on that.
You're making my ill,
Barbara.
I'm absolutely willing
to -- to do
the -- the liability
insurance.
And if you'd go down to 37%,
I'd be happy to take your deal.
[ groans ]
No. 40%.
40% -- you got a deal.
Let's do it.
CORCORAN:
You got it, baby.
They're making you out like
you're a thief in the night.
I thank you.
Appreciate it.
Yeah.
We'll do great.
He's not so bad.
You guys are welcome
to try it.
If I leave some,
would you --
would you be willing
to try it?
No.
No, they're
too close-minded.
All right, well, thanks, guys.
Appreciate it.
O'LEARY:
I did not see that coming.
You know I hate that.
Yeah, of course you hate it.
I don't care if you --
no, no.
you know why I hate it?
'cause I have a lot
of respect for you.
And by you investing in that,
you're giving credibility to it.
Listen, when my husband's taking
supplemental nutrients,
he functions better.
HILTBRAND: So, to
the four sharks that thought
that I was just selling
snake oil,
all I say is try my product.
If you still don't feel it,
then fine.
But just try it
before you knock it.
Do you like more patterns,
or do you like more solids?
My name is moziah Bridges.
And I'm Mo's mom, tramica.
And we live
in Memphis, Tennessee.
These are
some nice suits.
Fashion!
It just speaks to me,
and I like to look good,
and I like to feel good.
Mo's always been
a snappy dresser.
Even when he was 4 and I allowed
him to dress himself...
Looking good.
...He would choose to ride
his bike in a suit and tie.
You're doing
a great job.
BRIDGES: My grandmother was
a seamstress for a long time.
She taught me how to sew,
and after that,
my wardrobe got
a major upgrade.
I love fashion so much,
I decided to turn my passion
into a business.
It's a high-end
fashion accessory
that will have you
smiling and styling.
We could put these
on our website.
My fashion idol
is Daymond John,
and when I grow up,
I want to be just like him.
I need an investment from the
sharks to hire manufacturers.
My strongest suit
is designing,
and I need a team to bounce
my fresh ideas off of.
If I don't get a deal from
the sharks, I'll be very sad.
I need
to keep this dream alive,
because my passion
is your fashion.
Hello.
My name
is moziah Bridges,
and I am the C.E.O.
of Mo's Bows handmade bow ties.
And I brought with me
my lovely mom-ager.
Hi, sharks.
I'm tramica morris.
And we're here today
seeking $50,000
in exchange
for 20% of our company.
Sharks, I always -- I mean,
always -- like to dress nice.
Even when I was little,
I would wear a suit and tie
just to go play
on the playground.
But the problem was, I couldn't
find any bow ties that I liked,
so my grandma,
she showed me how to sew,
and then Mo's Bows
became.
Now, we've actually
brought y'all
some amazing bow ties
to have, feel, and see
the quality of product
we offer.
Bow ties are classic,
but Mo's Bows bow ties...
Thank you.
...We like to call them
classic swag.
But by investing
in Mo's Bows today
means investing
in the future,
because we don't
just make bow ties.
Mo's story has inspired
people young and old
to tap into their passion.
Yes, I give everyone
the same advice --
figure out
what you like doing,
and find out how you can make
money doing it.
Figure out, find out.
It's that simple.
Sharks, I know that, together,
we can make a lot of money
and make this business
really, really successful
by helping people look good
and feel good in my bow ties.
So, I only just have
one question --
who's coming with me?
[ laughs ]
You're so charming.
Thank you.
Are you selling
any of these bow ties, mo?
Yes.
How many and to who?
I've sold, uh, 2,000.
2,000? Wow.
Wow.
Did you hand-make
2,000 bow ties?
Yes. Me and my grandma.
Yourself?
But you're doing it all
in your house right now?
Yeah.
You're running
a sweatshop.
Yes.
[ laughter ]
How old are you, mo?
I'm 11 years old.
Wow.
How long did it take you
to sell the 2,000?
We've been in business
for two years.
mo started when he was 9.
This year, we've sold
a total of 1,500 ties,
at a total of $55,000
in selling ties.
$55,000? mo.
Wow.
CORCORAN: Who are you
selling them to?
We sell online,
and we have 11 different stores
across the South.
How do people
find you, mo?
They find me
from different trunk shows.
My mom posted it
on Facebook and magazines.
I've been in
the Oprah magazine.
moRRIS: So he's gotten
a lot of publicity.
Wow.
How much does it cost you
to make one,
and how much
do you sell it for?
What it costs for me
to make one is $6 to $10,
and they range
from $45 to $55.
mo, why did you decide
on bow ties?
Because I really like
to dress up,
and, also,
my dad and my granddad,
they were
really dapper men.
[ laughs ]
And bow ties make you look good
and feel good.
I feel like I'm watching,
standing right before me,
Daymond John working with his
mother, making his clothes...
you know, baby D.J.
BRIDGES: Maybe.
...His first hats
in the kitchen.
HERJAVEC: Oh.
What do you think, Daymond?
Is that your new protg?
It could be.
I'm you in 30 years.
I wasn't doing that type
of business
at that age,
so congratulations.
What do you need
the $50,000 for?
We want to use
the $50,000
to go home and, um,
secure a manufacturer.
Do you anticipate a large
amount of orders, or are
you saying
that you already have orders
and you want to take the money
to utilize it for that?
Absolutely, both. We, uh,
currently have 11 stores.
We have about five more stores
that are waiting.
Any big-box players? Any large
fashion players interested?
Right now, he's reached out
to Macy's and Dillard's
and some
of the big-box players,
but right now it's
in specialty boutiques
throughout the South.
I'm gonna make
the assumption
that you're trying to build
a brand -- Mo's Bows.
I get it...
Mm-hmm.
...Because these
are expensive.
This is not
a cheap bow tie.
CUBAN: mo,
you're teaching Kevin
a very valuable lesson
in pricing elasticity.
Do you know what pricing
elasticity is?
No.
What that means is,
when you have more demand
than you can supply,
what do you do?
You raise your prices.
When you go
to manufacturing,
do you not lose a certain amount
of cache around it?
Because today,
it's handcrafted Mo's Bows.
Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm.
Mm-hmm.
If you have it manufactured,
is it still handcrafted?
I believe so.
Well, the -- the company that
we're working with in Memphis,
it's a lady that used to own
a sewing factory.
They're sewing,
they're cutting, so...
I see. And how many
can they make a day?
At least 500 a week.
What will your grandmother say,
mo, when you fire her?
Will she be upset?
Well, my grandma,
she's just funny.
She's just, "oh, okay."
CORCORAN: [ laughs ]
yeah, she's --
she's --
at 80 years old,
she's fine...
chill. everything.
...With pretty much
whatever we --
you're making an 80-year-old
woman work 10 hours a day?
[ laughter ]
Well, she loves me.
She loves the feel
of my cheeks the most.
JOHN:
mo, mo, are you gonna --
are you planning
on expanding the line
to other haberdasheries
and -- and other things?
Yes, I'm planning
to have my own clothing line
by the time I'm 20.
20? Okay, good.
Nine years.
Why do you believe
that you need an investor
instead of growing the business
steadily on your own
and making all the profit
for yourself?
Because I believe I am an
n.B.T. -- The next big thing --
and because I've been in --
oh, my goodness. did you just
say "n.b.t. -- next big thing"?
Yes.
[ laughter ]
moRRIS:
And we feel like,
with your funding
and with your connections,
we can grow faster,
we can really get
the brand out there.
And we want to take the world
of male accessories
and kind of turn it
upside down.
We want cool socks. We want
fun bow ties, fun neckties.
Guys, I'll get it started.
Um, I -- mo, you are
the next big thing.
Thank you.
I'm excited for you,
but as advanced
as my fashion sense is,
I don't know
if I'm the guy to help you.
I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
Mo, I-I appreciate you
coming out here today.
Thank you.
But, uh, I don't think I'm
the right partner for you.
There might be somebody else
on this panel
who might be
a better fit.
And for that reason,
I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you.
Barbara, Kevin,
Daymond?
I'll tell you what I'm
smelling right here. [ sniffs ]
HERJAVEC: What?
I smell a royalty deal.
NARRATOR: Two sharks are out,
but Kevin may be interested.
O'LEARY: I'll tell you what I'm
smelling right here. [ sniffs ]
HERJAVEC: What?
I smell a royalty deal...
[ laughs ]
Oh, my God.
...'cause your margins are
so high, they're incredible.
You could afford
to pay me $3 a tie
if I give you the $50,000.
don't do it, mo.
There's your first offer.
I'll give you the $50,000.
I don't want
any equity in Mo's Bows.
I want $3 every time
you sell a tie.
CORCORAN:
Here's my take on it.
Um, it's a family business...
HERJAVEC:
Hmm. That's true.
...And you're doing
very well.
Mm-hmm.
So it's not like you're
standing alone.
You're surrounded by people
that love you, support you,
and they're working
for you.
moRRIS: Okay.
And you're hardly grown-up.
[ chuckles ]
I honestly don't think
you need anybody's help.
I think you're
on to something here.
Your margins are great.
You're selling them.
If you could keep
the publicity going...
Mm-hmm.
...I think that is amazing,
and you being who you are,
why wouldn't everybody write
about you?
Yeah.
Right?
Absolutely.
For those reasons, I'm out.
JOHN: So, I-In 1989,
I was offered $10,000
for 40% of my company,
and my company was only a couple
of hats I made, right?
10 years later,
that would've been worth,
to somebody else,
$40 million.
I'm glad
I didn't take that money.
I strongly suggest
that you don't take on investors
at this time.
So I will guarantee
to mentor you,
but I will not give you
the money at this time.
And I think the mentoring
is way more valuable
than the money.
Absolutely.
So, in regards to the deal,
I'm out.
Okay.
In regards to mentoring,
I'm in.
Perfect.
And don't do this deal.
[ chuckles ]
O'LEARY: You know, here's
the thing, mo. I believed
in you from the beginning.
And the way I'm showing my
belief is I'm writing a check.
Everybody else -- talk.
You also will have
Mr. Wonderful as a mentor
instead of myself.
No, no,
you can also mentor.
Wow.
I won't -- I won't --
I wouldn't be able to do that
because you -- it will show that
you're not listening to me.
I want to take you
down the path that I want.
Wow! Listen to that.
Wow. Good move, Daymond.
He's telling you
not to take my money.
So once you do
10,000 ties,
think about sending
this guy $30,000
every time
you do your ties...
And you would've made
on that --
...Forever.
Mo, I-I know --
Mo, I know
it's a very -- it's a very,
very difficult decision.
What are you
going to do?
Well, we appreciate
all of your comments and
all of your feedback.
Um, Mr. Wonderful, Kevin,
we appreciate your offer,
but we're going
to have to decline.
Yes.
HERJAVEC: Yay!
Daymond, we would love
to -- to work with you
as a mentor...
absolutely.
...And take Mo to --
to the next level
of where --
of where he could go.
Do you agree
with that, Mo?
Mo? Okay.
Mm-hmm.
mo, you're thinking about it,
and mom doesn't like it.
I'm checking
with the C.E.O.
mo is the C.E.O., but I'm
the C.E.O. Of mo, so...
JOHN: There you go.
CUBAN: Good luck, guys.
Thank you guys so much.
We really appreciate
the offer. Thank you.
Good luck.
Congratulations, mo.
All right, and I'll be
speaking to you.
All right, perfect.
BRIDGES: I walked out with
Daymond John as my mentor.
Ba-zam!
I'm on my way.
And you know what I like
about him?
He said he's gonna do clothing
by the age of 20.
Nine years. He's not thinking
tomorrow, tomorrow.
He's gonna develop
his business.
I think you did him
a huge disservice.
I think you're an animal.
No, listen. I think that
would've worked beautifully.
[ chuckles ]